your team perfectly sets out dilemma of
today's worlds
we need cooperation yet we Face
fragmentation
and I'm not here to sugarcoat the scale
of that challenge or the sorry state of
our world
we can't confront problems unless we
look them squarely in the eye
and we are looking into the eye of a
category 5 hurricane
our world is plagued by A Perfect Storm
on a number of fronts
start with the short term a global
economic crisis the Outlook as we all
know is bleak
many parts of the world face recession
and the entire world faces a Slowdown
and we see deepening inequalities and
the rapidly unfolding cost of living
crisis affecting women and girls the
most
supply chain disruptions and an energy
crunch
soaring prices
Rising interest rates along with
inflation
and debt levels pounding vulnerable
countries
add to all of that the lingering effects
of the pandemic
covid-19 is still straining economies
with the world's failure to prepare for
future pandemics
that
failure is training our credulity
somehow after all we have endured we
have not learned the global Public
Health lessons of the pandemic we are
nowhere near ready for the pandemics to
come
and to all that another measure and
indeed existential challenge
we are flirting with climate disaster
every week brings a new climate order
story
greenhouse gas emissions are at record
levels and growing
the commitment to limit Global
temperature rise to 1.5 degrees
is nearly Going Up In Smoke
without further action we are headed to
a 2.8 degree increase and the
consequences as we all know would be
devastating
several parts of our planet would be
uninhabitable
and for many it will mean a death
sentence
but this is not a surprise the science
has been cleared for decades
and I'm not talking only about un
scientists
I'm talking
even
about
fossil fuel scientists
we learned last week
that certain fossil fuel producers were
fully aware in the 70s that their core
products was making our planet
and just like the tobacco industry they
wrote roughshod over their own science
some in Big Oil peddled the big lie
and like the tobacco industry those
responsible must be held to accounts
today fossil fuel producers and their
enablers are still racing to expand
production
knowing full well that this business
model is inconsistent with human
survival
now this Insanity belongs in science
fiction yet we know the ecosystem
meltdown is called hard scientific facts
and to this toxic brew yet another
combustible Factor conflict violence War
especially the Russian invasion of
Ukraine
not only because of the untold suffering
of Ukrainian people
but because of its profound Global
implications
on global food and energy prices on
trade and Supply chains on questions of
nuclear safety and on the very
foundations of international law and the
United Nations Charter
we are doing our best making progress
where we can particularly in
facilitating exports of food and
fertilizers from Ukraine and also from
Russia
but we are a far cry from peace in line
with international law and the United
Nations Charter now the truth is that
more and more businesses are making Net
Zero commitments but benchmarks and
criteria are often dubious or murky
and this can mislead consumers investors
and Regulators with false narratives and
it feeds the culture of climate
misinformation and confusion and leaves
the door open to greenwashing
that's why we created an expert group on
NetZero emissions commitments recently
the group has issued how to guide for
credible accountable Net Zero pledgments
and they're in at Davos I call on all
corporate leaders to act based on these
guidelines
to put forward credible and transparent
transition plans on how to achieve Net
Zero and to submit those plans before
the end of the year
now the transition to Net Zero must be
grounded in real emissions cuts
and not relying essentially on carbon
credits or Shadow markets we risk what
I've called a great fractures the
decoupling of the world's two largest
economies
tectonic drift that would create two
different sets of trade rules two
dominant currencies to internet and to
conflicting strategies on artificial
intelligence
this is the last thing we need
the IMF reported that dividing the
global economy into two
blocks could cut Global GDP by a
whopping 1.4 trillion US dollars
now there are many aspects in which the
US and China relations will inevitably
diverge particularly on questions of
Human Rights and on some areas of
regional security
but despite that it is possible and I
would say it is essential for the two
countries to have meaningful engagement
on climate trade and Technology
to avoid the decoupling of economies of
even the possibility of future
confrontations
to all of that the lingering effects of
the pandemic
covid-19 is still straining economies
with the world's failure to prepare for
future pandemics
that failure is training our credulity
somehow
endured
we have not learned the global Public
Health lessons of the pandemic we are
nowhere near ready for the pandemics to
come